[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم الموقف في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله وفي كامل منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بالغ الخطوره ويطرح مجموعه من
الاسئله المهمه جدا الاجابه على هذه
الاسئله تقتدي عقليه استثنائيه للاجابه
عليها وانا بدوري
باستضافه القليله في العالم العربي بدون
مقدمات ضيفي اليوم هو الاستاذ الدكتور علي
الدين هلال استاذ النظم السياسيه تخصصه
الدقيق استاذ العلوم السياسيه عميد اساتذه
العلوم السياسيه في مصر والعالم العربي
مساء الخير معالي الدكتور مساء الخير
وشكرا جزيلا على هذه الكلمات الطيبه ربنا
يخليك معالي الدكتور ربنا يخلي حضرتك
استاذنك نبدا
بالسؤال الملح والعاجل جدا في تقدير حضرتك
هل اسرائيل جاده فيما نسمعه عن محاولات
تهجير اهالي غزه الى سيناء فكره
التهجير فكره موجوده في الفكر
الصهيوني وفي الممارسات
الاسرائيليه منذ بدء الحركه الصهيونيه
العالميه وحتى الان الفكره موجوده يعني
حضرتك لو ترجع مثلا
لتيودور هيرسل الصحف النمساوي اللي هو
مؤسس الصهيونيه المنظمه الصهيونيه
العالميه هو في كتابه دوله
اليهوديه الشعار اللي رفعه شعب بلا ارض
لارض بلا شب معنى في هنا الشعب يقصد به
الشعب
اليهودي حسب تصوره مبعثر ومشتت في كل
الافاق تعرض للاضطهاد وفعلا اليهود في
روسيا
القيصريه تعرضوا ل مذابح جماعيه واضطهاد
كبير 1882 على مضبوط سم البجم
و ل ارض بلا شعب يعني هذا
الزعم ان ارض فلسطين كانت ارضا خاويه من
السكان انما هو كان ده غير
حقيقي فحضرتك تقرا في مذكراته كان كاتب
بيكتب مذكرات يوميه
ومذاكرته ترجمتها ا هلده ا
صايغ وحررها الدكتور انيس صايغ وصدرت عام
68 يوميات يودور
هرتسل
فكاتب اذا لم تخني الذاكره في يونيو 95
1895 هو عارف الارض مليانه ناس فيكتب يقول
علينا ان نبدا باستملاك الارض وطرد السكان
تدريجيا وباعلى درجه من
الاحتراز وعلينا ان نبحث لهم عن
اعمل
وماوى في البلاد التي سوف يذهبون اليها
الصديق صدوق لتيودور هيرتزل كان راجل اسمه
صحفي كاتب انجليزي اسمه اسرائيل
زنجل مشهور جدا فدوت جه فلسطين وشاف
الدنيا فيها ايه بعد كده كان القى
محاضره قال فيها ان الكثافه
السكانيه في ولايه القدس تمثل ضعف الكثافه
في الولايه
المتحده يعني من حيث عدد السكان لكل
كيلومتر مربع وانه علينا ان نعمل على
اخراج الناس دول ط نقول ده كلام يعني
افكار لما نرجع لعام 77 وصدور قرار
التقسيم عن الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
اكتوبر
47 وقالوا بقى بس يعني احنا في نزاع شعبين
بيقتلوا على ارض واحده
ا فاذا ما دام مش عارفين يعيشوا في سلام
مع بعضهم فل تقسم الارض وصدر قرار
التقسيم اذا ا بحيث تنشا حسب تعبيراتهم
دوله يهوديه دوله عربيه ودوله عربيه وتدو
الاماكن المقدسه قبل يعني هي انجلترا
المملكه المتحده اعلنت نهايه الانتداب يوم
15 مايو 48 بمجرد صدور قرار التقسيم
بدات الميليشيات العسكريه التنظيمات
العسكريه اليهوديه على رس الهجنه اللي هي
اللي هي نواه الجيش الاسرائيليه كانت تبع
الوكاله اليهوديه ثم التنظيمات العسكريه
التابعه للاحزاب زي اليرجون زي
شتيرن بدات عمليه تصفيه
واخراج
لل فلسطينيين من قراهم من قراهم وفي يعني
اشهر واحده اللي هي مذبحه اللي هي في دير
ياسين اه عن
48 هل دي كانت اعمال فرديه يعني تصرفات
ولا منهج عمل لا منهج عمل منهج عمل يثبته
ده كان جزء من حاجه اسمها خطه ديلت
ديلت او تسمى خطه دي
اللي هي عمليه
منظمه خطه رسمتها الهجانه
ل
افراغ المناطق التي كانت مخصصه للدوله
العربيه من
سكانها وبالتالي اصبح المبدا ايه اكبر قدر
من السكان اسف اكبر قدر اصبح المبدا هو
اكبر قدر من الارض باقل عد بين السكان
انتهى الامر الى ايه بينما كان قرار
التقسيم تقريبا مقسم فلسطين بولت اكبر قدر
من الارض باقل عدد من السكان انك هتهجر اه
تمام هتاخد ارض وهتخليها تمام يبقى انت
بتاخد ارض كبيره جدا طب النتيجه بقول لك
بقى ايه ادي نموذج مش بس الافكار التهجير
ليه ممارسات التهجير مار اذا التهجير كانت
ا فكره قائمه ثم خطه منذ اللحظات الاولى
ميلاد الحركه الصهيونيه مظبوط كده الكلام
ده خطه دالت دي
دالت طبقت من ابريل الى مايو
48 اللي هو الشهور السابقه
ل اعلان الدوله اكتر من 500 قريه اخل
سكانها تماما هذه هي النجبه الاولى مع
الدكتور مضبوط 47 48 بس عايز اقول لك ايه
الدليل بقى على كده ايه ما هو الدليل على
ما
اقوله انه قرار
التقسيم كان بيدي من ارض فلسطين كان
اليهود حوالي
54% من الارض
والفلسطينيين حوالي 46% من
الارض 15 مايو
48 اصبحت المساحه التي نشات عليها
اسرائيل
78% من
الارض وتقلصت المساحه اللي هي
نظريا للدوله العربيه الفلسطينيه الى
22% الفرق بين ده بين 54 46
الى 78 22 ادي التهجير القصري وبالتالي
يعني وطبعا ال 22 دي تقلصت
المستو فاحنا بنتكلم على تقريبا 11% الان
11% واذا في مفاوضات قد تكون نسبه اقل
للاسف الشديد يعني اذا في مصونات لاقامه
الدوله فلسطينيه اقل من 11% اه اقل من هذا
لان المصونات قاعده تنمو وتنتشر مستوطنات
يكاد ا كل شهر في تجد مستوطنات جديده الى
اخره التهجير في العقليه الصهيونيه الاسيه
موجود تنفيذه يتوقف على الظرف
الزماني يعني عايز اقول ايه ناخد المثال
الاخير اللي هو موضوع
غزه لو كانت مصر تهاونت او الاردن تهاونت
وقالوا يعني يعني اخذوا موقفا مائعا
او
مرنا لا لاقدم على
التهجير وزير الخارجيه الاردني قال يعتبر
حاله حرب ده صحيح
اي محاوله تهجير جده هي اعلان حرك ومصر
يعني موقفها ثابت على لسان الرئيس
جمهوريتها على اسان وزير خارجيتها وعلى
اساس الراي العام المصري ان هذا يعتبر
مشاركه في تصفيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه اذا الاجابه هم جدون لكن لكن
وجدوا انه ظ غير مح الظرف غير متاح لكن
احنا عندنا ما نراه حتى الان احنا ما
نعرفش هم نواياهم ايه او احنا ع عرفنا
نواياهم بس مش عارفين هم هيستلموا امتى
لان نتنياهو قال كلمه خطيره ان استطاع او
او يعني تمكن من البقاء حتى ينفذها انه
نيته ان يجعل من غزه شانا دوليا يعني يخلي
يحدف قطاع غزه كده تبقى مشكله
للاخرين فمشكله للاخرين ديت اما بمحاوله
اجبارهم على النزوح لمصر زي ما بيحاولوا
يعملوا دلوقتي او حتى لو ما تمكن هو ممكن
جدا
هو دلوقتي اغلق المعابر من كل مكان واصبح
معبر رفح هو الوحيد اللي مفتوح للحياه
ممكن يجعل هذا الوضع او يفكر في ان يجعله
وضعا طويل الامد في الحاله دي ماذا سوف
يحدث لا هذه يعني الاول بس عايز اقول ايه
في اوقات
الازمات
بتكثر الاخبار
الكاذبه التعليقات
المغلوطه لان احد سمات الازمات نقص
المعلومات هو بيبد
تفتح القنوات
التلفزيونيه مئات الاخبار انما جزء منها
حرب نفسيه وجزء منها اخبار يقصد بها
التاثير على معنويات الطرف الاخر او
مناصريه وبعض الاخبار البعض هذه بيتردد
انها اخبار المقصود بها التاثير على الراي
العام الدولي وبالتالي الباحث او المحلل
عليه ان يعني او لا ينسق را الحاجات دي
وان يحاول يحتكم الى
الوقائع ايه الوقائع ايه اللي
حصل اللي حصل كثير من اللي قالوا نتنياهو
لم
يتحقق وهرد على سؤال حضرتك يعني هو يعني
لما بدا الحديث عن المعونات الانسانيه
واتقال يوم الجمعه يوم الجمعه ما حصلش
وقال 10 شاحنات فقط اللي حدث في اول يوم
20 شاح 20 شاحنه ويومها بالليل 17
شاحنه
ولغايه عده ايام اكثر من 120 شاحنه و يعني
احنا النهارده بنسجل يوم
الاثنين في الاتصال التليفون 30
اكتوبر 20
2 بالامس بايدن الرئيس الامريكي اتصل
بالرئيس المصري السيسي وبرئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو و البيان اللي صدر عن البيت
الابيض وع رسه رئاسه الجمهوريه قال
الرئيسان اتفق على انتظام ارسال البعثات
والمعونات
الانسانيه بشكل مستدام
ودائم فاللي انا عايز اقوله الكلام شيء ط
الحديث بس ادي حضرتك مثال تاني الحديث
انه الغزو واحتلال غزه ما حصلش يجوز يحصل
في المستقبل لكن لغاد دلوقتي لما اشوف من
امتى بداوا يتكلموا في هذا واعطاء
الانطباع انه على الوشق من عده ايام قاللك
ان هذه الليله سوف تكون الليله الحاسمه
وسوف نريك مقضب انا مظبوط الله وبعدين
يقول ان هذه الحرب
ا في بقى كلام
جنون يعني الجزء ده ا الفرمن تاطير
نتنياهو استخدم تعبير اننا نخوض حرب
الاستقلال
الثانيه هو يعني ساب كل 67 و56 و وبيط على
طول بين
48 الحرب دي القات العربيه دي حرب
الاستقاله الاولى لليهود ليهود اه ودي
الانيه
ا وبعدين اول ما
حدث 7 اكتوبر يربطوها بالمحرك الهدف هنا
المحرقه النازيه في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه الحرب العاليه الانيه الهدف هنا
ابتزاز الغرب و انك
بتحي في المجتمع
الغربي المسيحي او الغربي عموما يعني
الذكريات الاليمه لما حدث وا شعورهم
بالذنب ارجع بقى الى سؤالك هو بيقول قضيه
عالميه ويجوز اجابتي ه تدهشك هو رايه هو
الليز هو نفسه ان ايران تخش الحرب ايران
تدخل الحرب نتنياهو يتمنى يتمنى في هذه
الحاله اتمنى دخول ايران الحرب هو هو نفسه
انه
تتسع ساحه المواجهات اذا دخلت ايران
امريكا هتخش ما تعرفش هيحصل ايه بعد كده
هيشت عل العالم يكوز في الحاله دي بقى
تحدث عمليات هجوم على سفارات دول في حتت
مختلفه او عمليات عنف هنا وهناك الى اخره
ا يعني اللي حصل ما بين امبارح والنهارده
في مطار دغز استان
اه يعني اي انفجارات مختلفه في دول مختلفه
يا اما ضد اشخاص يهود واسرائيليين
او ضد منشات اسرائيليه هو نفسه شوف نفسه
حاجتين ليه حتى يتمتع باكبر درجه من الوقت
لممارسه اكبر قدر من العنف ضد الفلسطينين
ده اللي هو عايزه تتسع الحرب بحيث تبرر
لله مدون على الفلسطينيين ويبقى في ساحات
كثيره يبقى احداها غزه يعني مثلا انا ادي
امثله دي
يعني الفارق بين
الواقع
والاز يعني دلوقتي من يتحدث عن اوكراني
ولا حجه ولا اعلام دولي ولا اعلام كذا ولا
حاجه احنا في بلادنا العربيه بتدور في
جنوب مصر السودان حرب عنيفه جدا جدا
السودان وامبارح
تحديدا يعني
الاحد 29 اكتوبر في دارفور ولايه دارفور
برضو دمر اكبر مستشفى اللي هو بيعمل كذا
كذا ك ومئات القتلى انما مش واخذ التغطيه
الاعلاميه اللي واخدها لان الحدث كل
الكاميرات على غزه هو نفسه
انه تتسع هذه الحرب واتسع ساحتها بحيث
يبقى عنده وقت اطول يحقق فيها اهدافه انا
عايز اقول ايا كان الحرب حدته ازاي حقق
الفلسطيني وون انتصارا
استراتيجيا لا رجعه فيه بغض النظر عن ما
يحدث النهارده وبكره وبعد بكره لو حضرتك
عايز تناقشني في ده ا ا طبعا طبعا بالعكس
ده انا مهتم جدا لان ده احد موضوعات الجدل
اللي مطروح الان احنا عندنا تيارين تيار
حضرتك بؤي الان ان ما ان عمليه طوفان
الاقصى في 7 اكتوبر كان انتصارا
استراتيجيا للفلسطينيين وتيار اخر يقول دي
كانت خراب عليهم وان هي جلبت الخراب
للفلسطينيين وورثت الدول المختلفه في
مشكلات مادام راي حضرتك انها كانت انتصارا
في ريت توضح لنا كيف كانت انتصارا هو
الناس اللي يعني بيعترض على هذا الراي
يقول لك ايه يبدا
بالتشكيك او
بشيطنة انقلاب عسكري وان هي
ا تيار هو في الحقيقه الاخوان
المسلمين كل هذا
صحيح كل هذا صحيح واضيف عليه لمن لا يعرف
انه بدايه نشاه حماس كانت بمباركه
اسرائيليه ده
صحيح لكي تصبح عنصر موازنه في الانتخابات
البلديه ضد فتح ده صحيح كان وقتها العدو
هو فتح فتشجيع قيام جماعه اسلاميه لها
برنامج مختلف يؤدي الى فرقه ايه اللي حصل
غير كده بغض النظر مين اللي عمل ده وايه
اهدافه هو الشخصيه من هذا اللي عمل 7
اكتوبر 7 اكتوبر بيغض النظر ايه اللي حصل
على ارض الواقع
واحد انه تلقت
اسرائيل اكبر مفاجاه
عسكريه استراتيجيه
وتكتيك من 50 سنه من 6
اكتوبر ولا اريد ان اثقل على يعني على
المشاهد الكريم انحكي تفاصيل
هذه اللي انا بس عايز اقوله ايه الجدار ده
اللي هم م بنينه المؤكد المؤكد انه مبني
بحمايه الكترونيه انا اسف لو صرصار مشي
يتم رصده
لو حمامه طارت يتم رصدها فكيف يستطيع اكثر
من ال000 فلسطيني عمل ثغرات في الجدار فتح
ابواب الجدار والخروج والعوده مره تانيه ب
محتجزين بعد ل قتله حوالي 1400 وعشرات
الموتوسيكلات
والجرافات رايحه جايه لمده ست ساعات
يعني دي ضربه كبرى وعشان اريح حضرتك كل
اللي شفهم دول هيروحوا المحكمه كل
المسؤولين اه مبوط من نتنياهو لوزير
الدفاع لرئيس المخابره كل دول هيروحوا
المحكمه وانا اعتقادي ان جزء من العنف
الغاشم لتبرئه مج وجههم يروحوا المحكمه
يقولوا احنا غلطنا اه حصل كذا كذا بس احنا
عملنا حاولنا التعويض حاولنا التعويض انما
ده لن يغفر لهم لان حجم التقصير ده نفس
اللي حصل بعد 73 وتشكلت لجنه اجران القاضي
اجران وطلع تقرير ضخم كان اسمه هام حدال
التقصير ف الناس دول يعلموا انتهى يعني
نتانه المستق السياسي انتهى وكل
الاخرين الحاجه الاولى انت توجهت الى الى
المؤسسه العسكريه والسياسيه الحاكمه في
اسرائيل
ضربه لن يعني لسنوات عديده عديده عديده
سوف تظل قائمه في الا اثنين انت وعز بقى
ان اعترف بالحقائق انت قعدت على جدولى
اعمال العرب والعالم قضيه فلسطين هذا صحيح
يعني كان كان الباحثين كانوا بيرص دوا في
كل
المحافل يعني اصبحت قضيه فلسطين جزء من
الاعمال
الروتينيه ادانه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
اراض الفلسطينيه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الحقه والدعوه الى حل سلمي واحياء مسار
السلام الى اخره وفي اجيال طلعت شباب ما
يعرفوش اصلا القضيه الفلسطينيه الا بعد 7
اكتوبر صح فاذا انت قعدت سواء على مستوى
الراي العام العربي
والدولي الى اخذك زي ما 73 اعاده طرح
القضايا العربيه والحقوق المصريه والسوريه
ال السح مظبوط اللي بيؤكد
دوت يعني لو نرصد يا
استاذ
سيد احنا قلنا بنتكلم يوم الاتنين 30
اكتوبر مظبوط احنا يوم الجمعه كان في
القرار
العربي اللي صدر من الجمعيه العا الجمعيه
العا حصل هو بوقف الدعوه الى هدنه دائمه
فتح المعبر
ل مساعدات كذا كذا رفض اي افكار للتهجير
او ان الفلسطين على
اراضيهم واخر حاجه فيه ان هو التفكير في
حل سياسي الدولتين وده كان باغلبيه اغلبيه
صوت معارضه 14 صوت ابناء عن التصويت 45
صوت المؤيدين يعني بس تقول كده العلامات
الكبرى طبعا كل الول العربيه ما عدا ما
عدا العراق
وتونس
ويعني طلعوا كده بيانات ما معناه ان هم
كانوا عايزين قرار اكثر تشددا اه ماشي انا
مش عايز يعني احنا في وقت انا شخصيا اقول
ده لم شمل ولازم العرب يقفوا مع بعضهم
وبالتالي يعني
ا ممتنع عن التعقيد
على على الموقف العراقي والتونسي اه لان
في دول اكثر ثوريه
بكثير الجزائر الجزائر طبعا سوريه يعني
يعني في دول يعني لو اقول على مقياس
الثوريه يعني ايدت القرار انها تع ده اقصى
الممكن في هذه الظروف المعارضين طبعا على
راسهم الولايات المتحده واسرائيل ده طبيعي
طبعا بضيه وبالتالي يعني الام وابنتها
مظبوط كده حضرتك تعبير ادبي بليغ امريكا
في هذه الحرب يعني
شريك شريك وداعم
وحليف انما خد بالك بيحاول ايضا يوجه
اسرائيل يعني
هم مش عايز اقول اجبروهم ضغطوا عليهم
بالتمهل في الغزو البري وهم ليه
مصالحهم برض بيقولوا لا ادي او ويه ل او
ادي اهتمام اكبر للافراج عن الرهائن اللي
منهم امريكان واللي منهم امريكان بس
استاذن حضرتك يا معال الدكتور انت قلت ده
في اطار ان ده الوجه الثاني للتدليل على
الانتصار او على ان 7 اكتوبر فحضرتك قلت
الاول انها ضربه كبيره وم والثانيه احياء
القضيه ديت والثالث الثالث يعني حضرتك لو
تتامل في احنا النهارده يوم
الاثنين 30 اكتوبر ا اخر يوم مين يعني بعد
صدور القرار غير الملزم بتاع الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده حت جد في تحول في
الراي العام الدولي وضغط على
حكومته يعني بمعنى انه لا كفى
لهذا العنف العبثي ما حدش د بيتكلم على
حماس ولا ادانه حماس اللي هو كان من 10
ايام ده الاساس في في احاديث الغرب
اليومين اللي فاتوا في وول ستريت جورنال
وفي نيوورك تايمز كلام على كيف مارست
امريكا ا ضغوطا على اسرائيل لعمل كذا لمن
عمل كذا ثم الحديث الشرط ليه مع الرئيس
السيسي ومع رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو بخصوص
دور ضمان استمرار كذا وكذا
وكذا يعني معلش هستخدم تعبير مصري حركه
الجدعانه اللي عملها ايلون ماسك من
يومين ايوه اللي هو عمله مع اوكرانيا اللي
عمله مع واللطيف هنا قو محاوله توفير
انترنت او قوه السوشيال ميديا ان هو عمل
ده بعد ترند ضخم جدا من الشباب العربي
يدعوه فيها
ا ايلون ماسك غزه ستارلينك بس ففرح استجاب
اليها اجبرت اسرائيل برض امبارح انها تعيد
خط الميه بص يعني في ديناميات للحدث ف برض
امبارح والنه ده وكذا ا الرئيس الفرنسي مع
رئيس الوزراء الانجليزي بيقوللك لابد من
العمل على ضمان هدنه
والمباحثات الرئيس الامريكي اذا هم بين
نارين نار الصداقه التقليديه لاسرائيل الى
اخره والضغوط المتزايده عليهم من الراي
العام بتاعهم اذا عاوز استاذ نحرك معالي
الدكتور لان الحديث شايق جدا وانا في نفس
الوقت لدي الكثير من الاسئله الاخرى اخرى
فانا استاذنك ان انا الخص ما فهمته من
حضرتك قبل ان انتقل الى السؤال الاخير ما
فهمته من حضرتك وارجو ان تصححي لو اخطات
انه فكره التهجير ليست وليده 7 اكتوبر
2023 هي فكره مستقره مستقل مستقره في
العقل الصهيوني منذ نشاه الحركه الصهيونيه
كفكره ثم كمخطط بينتظر من وقت لاخر فرص
السانحه علشان ينفذ هذا التهجير احسنت
وانه تهجير الحالي او في الفتره الاخيره
او في اكتوبر الحالي تصور نتنياهو والسلطه
الحاكمه ان اللحظه كانت سانحه لكن ما منعه
او ما احبط مخططاته حتى الان هو الممانعه
العربيه والدوليه وخصوصا من مصر والاردن
وطبعا
الفلسطينيين مضبوط معنا الدكتور نعم اثنين
ان حضرتك بتعتبر ان ما حدث في 7 اكتوبر
رغم كل ما فيه من ماسي وخسائر هو انتصار
استراتيجيه للفلسطينيين لانه الحق هزيمه
النكراء بالاسرائيليين لانه اعاد القضيه
الفلسطينيه على الساحه الدوليه مره اخرى
لانه اتى بنوع من التعاطف الدولي مع
الفلسطينيين مره اخرى رغم صداقتهم
التقليديه مع الاسرائيليين واحياء حل
دولتين واحياء حل الدولتين بس حضرتك قلت
حاجه رغم ان انا عندي اسئله كتيره لكن
هستاذنك اكتفي بسؤال اخير ثم نرجئ للاسئله
الاخرى لحلقات قادمه حضرتك قلت معلومه
خطيره ان في تقديرك انه نتنياهو اللي
حضرتك قلت ان هو بيقول كلام كثير لكن في
الغالب لن يستطيع تنفيذ كل كلامه المبالغ
فيه هو من مصلحته الان ان يطيل امد الحرب
حتى يتمكن وانه يجر اطراف اخرى على راسها
ايران ووكلائها عشان يحقق هدفين الهدف
الاولاني ان يطول امد المعركه وبالتالي
يستطيع ان ينفذ اكبر قدر ممكن من اهدافه
في غزه ومن اهم اهدافه الانتقام اللي
هيحاول انه
يستخدمه لتبرئه نفسه او للتخفيف يعني من
الذنب والتقصير اللي ارتكبه امام الراي
العام الاسرائيلي انما ده معناه اذا هو
سعل لذلك وتمنى ذلك وحقق جزءا منه اننا
ربما نكون على اعتاب حرب اقليميه الحرب
الاقليميه لها اطراف هو رغبته
كده السؤال هل الاطراف الاخرى حت تجاوب
معه ولا لا وايه حساباتها الطرف الرئيسي
في هذا الشان هو ايران طب نشوف ايران عملت
ايه واحد تاني او ث ايام الحرب اتصال
تليفوني نادر من وزير الخارجيه الايراني
الى وزير الخارجيه المصري اثنين
امبارح الاحد
29 اتصال تليفوني وبيان مشترك بين وزير
الخارجيه الايراني ووزير الخارجيه
السعودي الدعوه الى الهدنه ووقف التصعيد
ثلاثه
لما نشوف العمليات العسكريه اللي في جنوب
لبنان حزب الله منضبطه
منضبطه ممكن
تزيد فيها خطوره اضطرت اسرائيل
تفرغ تفرغ المستوطنات 5 كيلو
متر انما ماقدرش اقول ان
الجبهه جبهه الجنوب اللبناني
انفتحت
اذا احنا ل بنحلل لكن الظروف تتغير لكن
حتى الان
تحليل الحسابات الايرانيه انها حسابات
دقيقه ومنضبط ولا ترغب في دخول في ولا
ترغب في الدخول في حرب كبرى لا ترى ان ذلك
من مصلحتها في هذا التوقيت ب عن مصلحه
ايران
وحساباتها
وموضوعات اخرى اذا حضرتك ان احنا
نناقشها في حلقه مقبله باذن الله ان شاء
الله جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور وربنا يخلي
حضرتك شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم